[Music]
what's up guys
welcome to culture binge the wisecrack
podcast where we explore
the cultural zeitgeist for all it has to
offer i'm michael
joined by wisecrack former new jersey
mall santa alec and wisecrack researcher
and of course our number one tipper
serbie
um how are you all doing today thanks
how are you
great did everyone have a lovely and
safe thanksgiving
week holiday i ate a bunch of potatoes
and stayed home
what more could you ask for wow that's
great what was your favorite thing that
you ate during the holiday serbie
i ate 20 cookies
[Laughter]
okay need more information one sitting
over
what kind of what kind of cookies um
two settings multiple bags of uh
chocolate chip cookies from trader joe's
it was delicious um wait they weren't
homemade you just ate
cookies out of a bag yeah because
i mean it's sad and that's life
but also magical it was so good i felt
really good about myself afterwards
i mean i finished eating them and i was
like oh gosh i really accomplished
something amazing today
that's incredible and i think that
survey's reminding us all that you can
do anything if you put your mind to it
okay so sorby thank you so much for the
information about your cookie eating
adventures um
and everyone if you find that
interesting let us know in the comments
and we can start a spin-off show called
cookie binch where once a month serbia
eats her favorite grocery store brand
cookies and reviews them okay so we're
still doing our all slaps and no chap
special because the world itself is one
giant chap right now
so let's talk about something that's
slapping that's making you feel good
that you're enjoying alec we'll start
with you
what's slapping i'm reading the expanse
uh the
book series there's a tv show based off
of it it's very cool it's like an
anti-star trek it is
to star trek what say george rr martin
is to tolkien i highly recommend it on
the second book
70 of the way through it it's real good
amazing um so read that if you like to
read things
uh serbi how about you i really like
money heist on netflix it's about a gang
of
bank thieves um all of the characters
are really interesting the actors are
great the storyline is so fun i really
love it
oh is that is that the spanish show i
think yes it's the spanish show
i've heard that's great awesome well and
can people is that on streaming
it's on netflix yes it's on stream so
awesome watch that on netflix and then
after you watch
money heist my slab is also on netflix
there's a new special it just came out
on december 1st on netflix it's called
nate it's a one-woman show by this
comedian actor genius named natalie
palamides
and it's a live show where this woman
plays a guy named
nate and it explores issues of
gender consent it's very uncomfortable
it's very funny it involves audience
participation i was at one of the live
shows where i intentionally sat
three rows back because i didn't want to
be involved in the show at all if that
tells you anything about it
but it's really powerful really funny so
go watch that
um and then before we get into our
topics today just a reminder you should
subscribe and and rate
and and review and all those things uh
the the of this podcast we like it we
appreciate it
and i think we actually have a a review
um from recently so the last time i
asked you
all if if you wanted to review the
podcast on itunes or whatever
what you could do is is say which
cocktail we would all be or a beverage
and someone actually did this clark0717
i won't read the whole thing it's
incredible
um but clark 0717 did say this serbia a
hot toddy
that's a good drink michael a margarita
i'll take that and alec
a black russian um and i will say that
part of alex description was not afraid
to go into the darker sides of the
cultural zeitgeist
um oh and that's from dave so dave thank
you so much for doing that
but please subscribe rate review and if
you want to have fun with your review
tell us which cocktail we would be what
food item we would be
who would play us in a movie something
like that it's fun okay so
now that that's out of the way let's get
into our topics um the first one is
is mine so i wanted to talk a little bit
about gender dynamics and sports and
this is sort of motivated by
what happened over the weekend a lot of
people heard the story um but a woman
named
sarah fuller made news when she was the
first woman to play in a men's college
football game
for a power five team now there have
been two women who previously um
played in college football games but
they were in sort of like lower
conferences
so this is the first time someone in one
of the big five conferences and these
are the sort of teams that like
i don't know if you get up early on
saturday and turn on fox or abc or
something the type of games you will see
now she took on kickoff duties and for
anyone that doesn't know anything about
sports
this is when you kicked the ball at the
beginning of the game to get things
going
um and she ended up taking on that role
because a lot of the other players were
out due to covet because maybe we
shouldn't be playing football right now
now fuller already plays um goal for
vanderbilt's women's soccer team
um and she actually was a part of
helping them win their first sec title
since 1994. and this was a big deal
college football is a very uh i mean
historically male dominated sport a very
bro-y sport at that so having
a woman athlete starting a game you know
on tv
you know getting the kick off was a
really big deal and a lot of famous
athletes
responded to it um and it made a lot of
news there was also some people that
talked about it in very stupid ways when
i was researching this
i made myself read a federalist article
that was about how her doing this put
women back a bunch of years it was the
dumbest thing i've ever read in my life
but this also accompanies a lot of other
recent news
of women taking on roles in
traditionally male
dominated professional sports so another
story that broke a couple weeks ago
is that kim ang was hired as the first
general manager
first female general manager of the
miami marlins baseball team in the mlb
this makes her the first woman general
manager of
any professional sports team in north
american history
and the first asian american manager in
mlb history and this is after three
decades of her working in various roles
in professional baseball
um so that's a huge first over in
professional baseball
and then in the mba this isn't as recent
but it sort of goes along with this um
becky hammon who's an assistant coach
for the san antonio spurs
she's only the second female coach in
nba history and the first
full-time coach along with the first
female head coach in the nba summer
league first woman on an nba all-star
coaching staff
and she's been interviewed to be the gm
of a team before she got a gm interview
for the milwaukee bucks
and there's definitely talk that she has
a chance uh
to be the nba's first female head coach
uh or at least be interviewed for those
sorts of things and and all of this is
interesting because
if there's any sort of institution in at
least i'll speak to america i don't know
a ton about the dynamics of professional
sports around the world
an institution that is historically
deeply
male dominated it is professional sports
and in particular it's one of those last
areas of life where this gender divide
is so intense um and then and to give a
another smaller example that might not
be considered a professional sport
i've been thinking about ever since this
year's american ninja warriors finale
american ninja warriors are my favorite
shows i know i mentioned it before and
they did a
bubble version of the season due to
kovid but
um they did this tournament and the cool
thing about it is one of the final eight
people in the entire
competition was a woman named jessie
flex lebreck
um and the way they do american ninja
warrior is there's no
like men's and women's division everyone
competes together
so it was really cool in this sort of
athletic competition
that lets everyone commute together to
see a lot of the women get just as far
as the men and really compete for
the final thing there so i know that you
all are not
sports heads let's say is that fair yes
um but i mean have you all heard about
this and does anyone have any thoughts
on
sort of the idea of women starting to
take on roles in
men's sporting leagues i haven't heard
about it
but i'm really happy to hear about it
because i grew up playing a lot of
sports
and i always asked my mom why there
weren't
women in the like nfl
or mlb or anything like that um and the
answers was always just like well they
have their own league
and i'm like but why like why can't they
all be together why aren't there any
like coaches or
anything like that so it's nice to hear
that things like that are happening
um i don't have too much to add other
than it's really nice and i think the
women are
they have to be quite strong in order to
deal with so many men
all the time especially in a field where
it's dominated by men so much so
good for them yeah
i i i also don't know too much and i
probably should google this but i know
i've brought this up before
um well i i think it's interesting that
oftentimes sports puts up like a strict
barrier and they justify that strict
barrier of like oh there's no way that
like a woman could do these things that
like a man could do you know like you
know
win in a heavyweight boxing match or
something like that but then
in the cases that that they can sort of
keep up as a kicker or a pitcher or
anything else
they're like oh just kidding we don't
allow that so was it babe ruth or lou
gehrig or there was some
very famous player that got struck out
by a female pitcher
a very long time ago and immediately
they're like women are not allowed to
play
in major league baseball anymore so it
was it was it was never really like oh
they can't keep up because as soon as
they actually
at least one person was able to keep up
they're like no you're banned from the
sport
yeah yeah um and i mean i think it's
interesting too that obviously the
example of fuller is someone playing um
you know uh kim
aang is has never been a player but
worked in all these teams and becky
hammon i should have mentioned as well
who's
the first full-time female coach in nba
history
also played in the wnba also played in
the
uh russian professional basketball
league as well
um but it's just interesting because so
much of professional sports the culture
is tied up in these gender dynamics and
you know one of the reasons
why historically it's thought that women
couldn't like coach
or or be referees or a part of
organizations is that like
the culture was too tough or we can't
have women in the locker rooms and all
those sorts of things
so i'm really glad to see that dynamic
shift another thing and i forgot to
mention this and
i sadly didn't research this and get the
person's name that's on me
but the nba also got its first um woman
referee
in this past season or two seasons ago
and that was another thing where
there was all this talk of like well the
referees have to be old men because
why would anyone respect someone who
wasn't a man so it's been good to see
those boundaries pushed as well
and i think like i don't know i just
think it's it's good in general
and i know that maybe we're still a ways
away from having
um you know a woman who's like starting
on the team in the mlb nfl or nba to be
clear i hope that happens
but even having having it normalized
that women can be
coaches or referees or parts of teams or
on practice squads or whatever
i think is going a long way in like
blurring some really
unproductive divides in professional
sports and on the other side
aren't the sports seeing like a huge
surge in like female viewership for
instance like i feel like when i was
growing up
i didn't encounter you know a lot like
i've never liked sports and so when i
would see a bunch of men talking about
sports i'd be like okay i'm gonna
exit from this conversation and go like
hang out with the women who were talking
about something else
but now i can't do that as much and yeah
not that i don't support their choices
of what
of what women want to watch but it makes
my social life more difficult
is also yeah well no but definitely even
in like the the media
journalism and hosting side women have
taken on big roles you know shouts to
people like mina kimes and haley
o'shaughnessy and a lot of the other
younger women who are you know hosting
podcasts and doing on-air commentary and
writing for some of the big sports
publications it's just becoming
much less of a boys club unless you're a
part of like
barstool sports or something um and it's
been really good to see those things
open up because it's like
it's dumb historically like this idea
because you know there's this whole
thing um
i think this is like a bar stool meme
that like saturdays are for the boys
and that like what yeah um for anyone
who's not
watching this live uh sir we did a
lovely eye roll that really encapsulated
a lot of what i would want to say
but yeah there's so many ideas around
like male sports culture that like
saturdays when the boys kick it and
crush some frosty brews
and watch some games and i think that's
dom
and i think uh and as someone who like
likes sports
and thinks they're really fun i've
always i've often been
uncomfortable with some of those
dynamics
in that and sometimes i felt like i have
to like apologize for myself
as a sports fan um once again that's why
i still like the nba the best because
not all sports fans hashtag not all
sports fans you know
and once again that's why the nba is the
best they they did the best with covid
they're making leaps and
and strides in terms of their gender
dynamics they've been on the right side
of a lot of
like racial justice issues so um there's
good stuff there and this is also of
course why everyone should watch
american ninja warrior the only
professional sport
i i don't i don't mind that show i have
watched it and i enjoy it i find it much
more enjoyable than all the other sports
combined
um have there been any interviews with
these women to
ask about their experiences yeah so um
so uh kim aang for example the woman who
was hired as the general manager of the
miami marlins which is a huge first i
mean a running professional baseball
team
the new york times did a really big
feature on her a couple weeks ago
that gets into her family background the
story of how she got there and talking
about all the
you know hurdles she had to face to get
to the position she's in because she
worked in professional baseball for
30 years and in the as as far back as
the early 2000s
people she worked for had like are
quoted in this article saying like they
thought she
needed to be considered for general
manager positions and the consensus is
that she's the most
qualified first-time gm in the history
of baseball wow
because of everything she went through
to do that so yeah um a good amount
there
and then there's been a few big features
on becky hammond before as well um and
greg popovich who's the coach of the san
antonio spurs
uh that hired her for her job there and
he's he's great um
really good you know woke old guy it has
had
overwhelmingly positive things to say
about her as well as a lot of the
players who have been there so
um if anyone is interested in any of
this stuff via some simple googling
uh the world will be at your fingertips
just don't look at any of the weird um
incelly takes on any of these people
because
because you have better things to do
with your time matt now i'm very
you've you've made me interested i have
to look into the abyss
look into the abyss um but you know once
again the the simplest thing for all
this
if you if this sounds interesting you
know go on streaming and watch
the past season of american ninja
warrior i'm not going to tell you
i think i already told you the names of
one of the women that goes really far
but it's really incredible and really
fun to see
i don't know i i think and i know it's
silly that i'm so obsessed with that
show but it's just so cool
to see everyone compete together young
old
across gender lines sexual preferences
all sort of stuff it's just fun let's
let everyone compete together
i like that that's all i got yeah so
unless there's anything else we'll leave
it there
as always let us know what you think
about that but before we go any further
um speaking of games that we can all
play together
regardless of who we are i want to tell
you about a really fun card game
called uh forks in the timeline now i
know if anyone's heard of this before
it's a really cool game
um it allows you to join a journey of
discovery through the fabric of time
space and and open some some doors in
the multiverse okay so this game
features a hundred cards which present
alternative realities and a hundred
random questions
and you pair them up and you get some
really fun
wild combinations now this is something
you play with friends you all come up
with your answers
uh people are gonna say crazy stuff
funny stuff weird stuff so here's an
example
um so you're going to take a fork card
when you play this game maybe your fork
card says
in a timeline where the purge was a real
event then we get our question card you
got a second stack okay it's not it's
not hard you know what i'm talking about
second card says something like what
would make your parents proud
so here's what we're doing we're coming
up with answers to in a timeline where
the purge was real event
what would make your parents proud the
judge is going to pick their favorite
answers and we're getting points based
off that
so you're competing in ways that are fun
now
former legend of the game jared uh
of wisecrack fame the first person on
our mount rushmore
he liked this game and said it helped
him with his writing so if you're a
creative person that loves
that likes coming up with cool scenarios
or you want to have some new inspiration
forks in the timeline could really help
you with that um just examples of some
other questions that you could have that
could pair up
you know like in a timeline where there
was suddenly no scientific progress
would communism work in a timeline where
humans lived
under water is america the land of
opportunity
these are just some random pairs i'm
just picking those off the list you can
see that this is
this is really fun i kind of want to do
it right now but i know we have things
we got to do with this podcast
um now if you think this game sounds fun
which you should
i think it sounds fun you think it
sounds fun and this is also a thing we
we could play
we could play via distance with friends
whether that's sitting six feet apart
or digitally there's ways we can do this
um there's a link
in the show notes so check that out or
go go to and you'll remember this
forksinthetimeline.com that's
www.forksinthetimeline.com
and use the promo code wham wham
wham and you can get 15 off the game
i'm not kidding when i say this i'm
going to be playing this game soon
because i recently had a falling out
with my partner over a game of monopoly
it got too serious why would you ever
play monopoly
worst night of my life hated it when i
lost real bad i got real upset
then she got mad at me for being real
upset and i just said can't we play a
fun game a game where the stakes aren't
like
i'm better at managing real estate right
that's what forks something like force
in the timeline will be great for that
but we just get
to have fun screw around come up some
funny scenarios laugh
learn about each other and fall deeper
in love that's i so i think if you want
to spark your relationship
forks in the timeline if you want to
fall in love with a new partner forks in
the timeline if you want to reconnect
with a parent who just found you on
ancestry.com forks in the timeline
for example timeline is the type of
thing that i would love because i love
asking these types of questions like
what what would happen if your name was
like bartholomew
and this is so much better than that
it's the kind of thing that
would spark interesting conversations
and would help you
like see how a person thinks
and learn more about their perspectives
well listen if wisecrack ever did
something crazy like had like a all-day
stream or something maybe
we could work a game of forks in the
timeline into there i don't know it
sounds fun but once again
check it out forks in the timeline.com
type in wham
you're getting 15 off you're having fun
no one loses in this transaction okay
but speaking of losing and maybe having
a bad time at something that should be
fun
serbia i think you're here to tell us
about some issues with
safety and tourism and travel so
joy our wonderful producer sent us an
article
pardon sorry i just yelled wonderful
when you said joy our wonderful producer
to like
sort of second that notion i'm sorry for
interrupting
yeah really really disrupted my
tyrannous thought there um
so she sent us this article about a
volcano
eruption in new zealand last year and
new zealand officials recently filed
safety violation charges against several
organizations and
individuals after this eruption killed
22 people last year around this time
so white island was a popular tourist
destination
but due to increased seismic activity
for a couple weeks
experts raised the alert level
and despite these warnings private
companies were still taking tourist
groups
to the island and during one of these
trips
there was an eruption 22 people died and
those that didn't die had severe burns
and an official connected to the case
said the victims all had an expectation
they could go to the island believing
the organizations involved had fulfilled
requirements to look after their
health and safety this story made me so
sad because
when you're on vacation you're just
you're having a good time
and the worst thing happened so
i started to think a lot i've been
thinking a lot
about everything just because i have
nothing else to do and one of the things
that i've been thinking about quite a
bit
is traveling and i've been fortunate to
be able to travel quite a bit
and the one thing that i've been
thinking about the most is how
often i
have put myself in danger because i stop
thinking critically
when i'm on vacation and i get so
focused on seeing something or doing
something
that i don't take the time to research
properly or
to pause and consider my actions and
i'm not saying that the the victims of
this
volcano should have known better or
should have done their own research
but just more i'm thinking more about
how i'm an extremely cautious person
person by nature and i
i'm the type of person who researches
and plans and knows everything in and
out
but as soon as i'm on vacation it's like
i'm a completely different person
and i am i'm
probably more carefree and more fun but
also a bit more reckless
and it's a scary thing because it's
it's the sort of thing that i would
never do at home
but when i'm away from home i just
will put my life in the hands of others
very freely
um so i'm very curious whether the two
of you do the same thing or if you have
any stories or experiences when you felt
like that was a near mess and your
travels could have taken a bad turn
i mean like the psychology of what
you're exploring is really interesting
and if one of our
i know we have listeners that are like
experts in psychology and grad students
and professionals and if you know
there's a name for this this
symptom let us know but i definitely
relate to that feeling that you're out
of your normal comfort zone
and you you have less of this like it
almost feels like you have less of an
evolutionary
drive for survival like you feel like
things can't happen or like there's a
magical safety net
underneath you and i know i've been
places before where like
i've gone on hikes that i wasn't
supposed to go on and went to the edge
of a cliff because i thought it was fun
that i would normally
never do or you know gone out late in
cities i've never been before
where people speak a language i don't
understand and drink too much and just
thought everything would work out or i
would
never do that where i live so i do think
there is this sense sometimes we have
it's almost like we think that we are
the protagonist in some like
early 2000s self-discovery travel film
or something like our own little epray
love
and you have this invincibility bubble
around you
where everything is magical and i think
with like the volcano thing especially
with
with anything nature related like once i
went um
pretty uh did some gnarly rock climbing
in a different country and it's and i'm
terrified of heights and when i say
terrified of heights like i don't like
to
like i can't go on water slides at water
park because i hate walking up the
stairs because my legs start shaking
but you go someplace else and you start
climbing around and it's almost this
mindset of like this isn't real
what could happen i'm not at home so
everything's okay
uh someone needs to help us diagnose
this alec i wonder about you ari do you
become
a more reckless version of yourself when
outside of your home space
i've only traveled internationally twice
and the first time i was 19 i went to
costa rica
and uh i'm not a great planner and so i
i think what i did is i printed out like
the directions
i was staying at this place it was very
far away and i print out the directions
i never read them before i got there
basically i was reading one step like i
wasn't reading ahead and so for instance
i got on a bus
uh it took all day at night it just
stopped in this town and i was like all
right when's the bus going again and
they're like
no it's done for the night and so i was
like okay like i'm a broke 19 year old
now i have to find
a place to stay i stayed they're like
the bus will be back here at like 7 a.m
tomorrow to take you the rest of the way
i was like okay
then i get i i show up and the
directions just say like ask for
ricardo who will take you on a boat to
where you're staying
and so i just started asking strangers
where this guy is they're like oh he he
collects the trash today he won't be
here till tomorrow
so i have to find another guy to give me
a boat ride
and uh the man is very cool uh actually
his name might have been ricardo i'm
getting the names confused but
uh he was on a boat with a stranger he
stops the engine and approaches a boat
full of people
wielding machetes and i was you know
just like an ignorant 19 year old i was
like oh okay i'm going to die people are
going to hack me with some shades
turns out just fishermen carry machetes
and he was throwing them a six pack of
beer everything was fine
but like you know that's not that
process of what i did
is not maybe what little alc would do
and i i don't
now i i plan ahead and i have a partner
that forces me to plan ahead
but i mean it's still like you go to
another country
and like you book a tour guide and it's
like i'm getting in the stranger's car
and like who the [ __ ] knows but here's a
question do we think this is a good
thing like
because i the framework frame in which
we're talking about this is sort of like
in real life we're good
but then we go travel and we're like bad
or reckless
but should we be more open to experience
in our everyday
scenario or what is what we're really
saying that we get too
buttoned up in our day to day and we
should be you know serbie should be
travel servi
and normal alex should be you know
waiting for ricardo alec
like well i don't know i mean the one
half of serbi's story is like
this company that i feel like we're
talking about this company
like put their their clients at risk
because like they needed to keep
operating and then kill 22 people
and then the other side is just like
it's not a suspension of disbelief when
you're traveling but just like okay i'm
gonna show up
and i'm gonna trust that the tour guide
is gonna take me where i go need to go
they're not going to kill me in a car
accident they're not going to take me to
volcano that's about to explode
they're not going to take me to a
building that might collapse like we
there's that side of things as well
which i don't want to ignore i don't i
don't mean to completely deflect serbia
yeah we do not want to send people to
their deaths just to be clear i think
that
i could maybe be a little bit more
carefree in my daily life
but when i think back about like what is
the worst thing that could happen the
worst thing that could happen is i could
die in a volcano explosion
yeah er eruption and so i'd rather be a
bit more cautious and when i reflect
back on these experiences
when like i probably would have been
kidnapped in china
or the time the guy followed me for half
a day in paris
like things like that like make me they
they they make me go cold inside and
so at the time it was like oh that
i've seen that guy before like no i see
that guy again
and also where am i in china like i
don't even know where i am
and the doors aren't opening on this
taxi um
so yeah so things like that like it's
not so much like i
like i go down like a dark alley which i
also have done but it's also things like
like like why do i just stop thinking
and so this this thing about the the
volcano i
100 probably would have been like
volcano sounds amazing
let's go yeah without even just googling
like
what's the situation with the volcano
right now especially in new zealand
right i feel like new zealand is one of
those countries that i would intuitively
be like
this is a reckless or crazy place like
everything's safe here they have their
awesome prime minister who says
everything right
like four day work weeks are good a
volcano just seems so like clearly
dangerous you're like well if they're
taking them
it must not be you know like like no
one's like
hey we're gonna take you into this
burning building or like well they must
know what they're doing because
they wouldn't take me otherwise you know
yeah
then i guess the volcano thing too is
like how what is it about
what is it about our desire to like put
ourselves in positions that we know are
objectively dangerous like certain
things like
i have no desire to skydive right you
could tell me it's safe
but i'm jumping out of [ __ ] plane if
i do that doesn't sound fun
um whereas a volcano is the same thing
or like a volcano is something
that can cause massive destruction maybe
that just shouldn't be a thing we do
for fun whereas going on like i don't
know a hike
or a or a pub tour of dublin might be a
more normative way to spend some time
yeah yeah that makes sense
i mean this is all really very
depressing yeah well the
even more depressing thing is it's going
to be a long time until we can really
suss out and try out these theories
because i don't think any of us are
going to be going on international
jaunts
anytime soon according to cdc some small
groups of people i think it's
old people and healthcare workers are
getting vaccines in february or march
so it's just going to be so your grandma
can travel grandma
and like uh nurses and hospital workers
on a well-earned vacations
we'll just be living it a party oh my
god can you imagine if just like
like right now if i see any of my
friends traveling i'm like you're an
[ __ ] but if it was just like a nurse
really
like if i had a friend that was a nurse
just really flaunting like i'm going to
travel the world and be safe and like i
would be both jealous and be like
yeah you deserve it yeah maybe i
interject with one thing too
just because this is a thing that
happened in my life over the weekend if
you're going to travel right now
especially if you're going to travel
internationally
like that's what you're going to do that
you're going to do but keep it to your
damn self don't put it all over your
social media and want it it's the
stupidest thing i've ever seen um
this person would would never listen to
this podcast or watch it anyways
but a friend i guess traveled
internationally from america
and just like all over their instagram
stories and social media just like
documenting the trip
complaining about the plane it's like
dog what are you doing
sorry i'm surprised countries even are
letting americans in i thought it was
just like
croatia well and then this person is
like oh i wonder if they're going to let
me in at the border like if you have to
ask that question
maybe you shouldn't be going you idiot
yeah
we have a travel channel at work and one
of my co-workers went to i think it was
like
tahiti or bora or something like that
and it just like the whole thing was
like feels so good to be traveling again
and i'm like like i don't know man
yeah wisecrack our travel channel is
comparing where we got lunch in the
greater los angeles area
um and how alive it made us feel
so uh do we have a travel channel i'm
not in it we we don't we don't
um okay but i really like that topic and
i think
yeah i want to hear more about this and
if people have had stories
of travel like that we want to hear them
but we'll get to how you can tell us
that later
um speaking of you know death defying
controversy alec
supposedly there has been some news some
drama in the young
author space in particular young authors
or y.a authors on twitter talking about
classic literature
and things have gotten pretty heated can
you let us know what we need to know
about this
yeah and for context i generally avoid
like one random person on the internet
said something dumb
you know there's a lot of internet
content about that i want to avoid that
but these are all published by authors
one of them had a check mark um
they made they said something that i
think is well well a few people said
different things some of them i find
very dumb
uh but i'm not gonna name their names
just because like they protected their
tweets and
are getting harassed and i don't you
know i might want to criticize what they
have to say but i'm not gonna like go
harass them or encourage other people
to harass them or send them dms with
like horrifying messages so don't do
that
um but that being said uh there was a
tweet by a young adult author
uh who basically made a list uh which
was like what are like the worst classic
books it's fine like number one was moby
dick it's boring like should kids
be reading at school because it's going
to teach them how to hate reading that's
a that's a fair enough question like
you don't have to you could love moby
dick and still understand that like
maybe it's not right for freshmen in
high school anyway
author gets to uh number three the tweet
is okay i got distracted by
all of you tweeting me about these awful
classic books i've blocked but my number
three is the adventures of huck finn can
we stop with the racist books already
to which a young another young adult
author responded so much racism in that
book
there's a lot of exclamations between
the words um and then
another author said would i assume my
teachers were trying to teach me with
classics
incest is okay if your dad refuses to
confirm your siblings that's wuthering
heights
it's okay to obsess over a pass to the
point of stalking if you're rich great
gratsby
and racism am i right that's huck finn
um and so
i mean i think the the last tweet is
probably the dumbest
uh but i have a lot of thoughts and
could ramble but i'm
sure lots of you lots of you two of you
already
already have thoughts immediately what
do you think
this is so stupid i have so many
thoughts about this
so my thoughts about like the why a
like author community in general but
also about
this argument um so
you can use literature as a means to
discuss the history of racism
discrimination and other problematic
issues like literature shouldn't be
about providing idealized
versions of people and society it's
about storytelling and capturing
a snapshot of how people perceive the
world
and it's naive to think that
the that huckleberry the adventures of
huckleberry finn or
uh peter pan or um little house on the
prairie
promote racism because it overlooks the
fact that these
are complex storylines or characters and
you can think that someone is a good
person but that doesn't mean that they
have good ideas like good people can
believe bad things and i think that it's
important to remember that
and if you have issues with these things
you can look up critical responses it
doesn't teach
children that uh racism is okay or
incest is okay
it shows them about the diversity of
life and if it makes you uncomfortable
think about how it makes those targeted
groups feel
yeah and i think uh i was trying to
tangle apart at least with the last
tweet it's like not understand like the
great gatsby is a book about how
lusting after wealth will destroy you um
and so
when you know gatsby does all these
awful things it's not like
check this out it's super cool um and so
with huckleberry huckleberry finn is
really interesting and sort of to what
you said i think there's like legitimate
debates about it
um but i think like those are debates
that could be
or conversations that could happen in
classrooms and i actually
i read into it a little bit because i've
heard what i consider is like the dumb
criticism of it and i want to know if
there's like a better criticism of huck
then and so
just laid out for anyone who hasn't read
it huckleberry finn is written by mark
twain
um basically a a white kid runs away
with a slave named jim um real and you
know
this kid sees the humanity in jim a
slave while the rest of society is
trying to tell him that he's less than
human
all have shenanigans ensue whatever um
this is written in 1880
something right after the civil war mark
twain was an early
uh outspoken opponent of slavery and
racism
um at the same time uh what i did find
was like maybe the the smarter
criticism is that the third act
basically mark twain
started using like minstrel humor to
appeal to his white audience um but
again like ralph ellison who's like one
of my favorite authors i was looking
into this wrote a great essay
uh and i have that written down
somewhere um i started reading a little
bit of it
it is called uh
20th century fiction and the black mask
of humanity uh there's been like a lot
of talk about this mark twain and he
basically says the last
act of mark twain you know is important
to the story where other authors have
not said
the point is that's like the smarter
argument that you could still teach in
schools
the dumber version is like the book uses
the n-word but again it's depicting
you know pre-civil war south where
like it's about how the word is
dehumanizing uh
and so i feel like that's like a dumb
thing and one book even went so far
one one publication of it one so far is
to replace the n word with the word
slave
which is inaccurate because not everyone
being
some of the the people were free black
men uh which obviously they weren't
slaves so anyway that that's that's the
dumb part
and so i think that part of it's done
but i think
there is like a smarter part of this
argument that i don't know if it's being
made this is all in the context of like
what are like what's being assigned in
schools and i think the bad version of
this is like let's cancel huck finn
because it's bad but the other thing is
there's like lots of good books about
slavery about racism in america um i
haven't read huckleberry in a while but
i remember really enjoying it i think
it's a very important book and
i i would recommend to anyone who hasn't
read it at the same time like there's
other
you know great books by people like tony
morrison or octavia butler or
um you know ralph ellison or richard
wright about
you know whether it's racism in america
or slavery at the same time mark twain
is one of the few books that was sort of
written contemporarily
and so i think it could have a good
discussion with a classroom about like
hey
this guy like wants to disrupt slavery
but at the same time is like still
making these pitfalls so sorry that's my
rant
yeah um like i won't watch the original
star wars because i don't endorse
incestual desire but everything else
sounds good here no yeah
i mean there's almost nothing else left
to say because you all really hit
all the nails on the heads here it's a
stupid critique
that views literature and fictional art
as instruction manuals that give to
strip to give like advice on how to live
rather than descriptions of what the
world has looked like
at various points that allow the reader
to have they presume the intelligence of
the reader to
interpret and learn and listen and
explore
and i think that's something that upsets
me most about that is the idea that
these authors think that people are
idiots
and these people aren't intelligent
enough to read something
to understand the context and to see
what's going on it'd be like i mean like
if a film critic watched the wolf of
wall street
and was like i can't believe that this
film openly endorses
you know financial crimes and blah blah
blah it's like no
idiots the whole film is about this
guy's life falls apart
because of greed and selfishness and
blah blah fun movie too
um but yeah i i guess that's the part
that offends me the most
and it worries me that like i don't know
it worries me that things turn in such a
way where there's not
room for you know messy
fiction and films and satirical accounts
of things
that explore bad ideas through through
heightening certain contradictions in
culture
i don't know just bums me out yeah i'm
just gonna link them to the thug notes
videos
on some of these books we should do that
someone responds
not us someone who's listening or
watching respond to all these ya authors
don't say anything no don't no don't
respond to any of the no they've already
all right like
never mind protected anyway don't do
anything don't uh
i also think another issue is that i
think oftentimes with like dumb
criticism comes dumb backlash
like the bat the backlash to the dumb
thing is even dumber which is like mark
twain must be defended at all cost how
dare you because i think
again like he's a product of his time
possibly criticizable there the book is
certainly not perfect
and at the same time there are other
books about this topic that could easily
be taught but it's not like
[ __ ] mark twain he's he's cancelled it's
like oh
you know here's one book about slavery
but there's also like roots by alex
haley and alex haley made a bunch of it
up
and but like is that worse than what
mark twain did or you know there's
uh more there's you know beloved by tony
morrison which i think is
slightly after the civil war or you know
octavia butler has done some fiction on
there and so
it's not like hey we have all these
options what do we choose like i i think
the the response of
we have to keep mark twain in our
curriculum at all cost is dumb because
even though it's valuable like lots of
other things are also valuable
yeah it's a really good point that we
shouldn't be precious on either side of
this
yeah but yeah i think it's frustrating
that it's
authors that are saying this it's such a
superficial argument
and it's exactly what i would expect
from a young adult
author i used to work in
well i used to work in um like
that industry and like the book
publishing industry and so that's
exactly like the kind of like weird like
hive minded um juvenile
thinking like as soon as i saw the tweet
i was like
100 that's somebody from y a and i
looked it up and i'm like
yeah i i i'm like i'm honestly curious
because i know
it gets a lot of flack uh you know
there's like various controversies
and whatnot uh it seems very competitive
it seems like there's good y.a and bad
why
as they're all things with all genre but
it seems like there's a lot of drama and
whenever like
drama intersects with social issues
you know it can create like a lightning
rod of both like
undeserved but sometimes deserved
attention you know
yeah and i like why a i mean i've read
some why a there's some really great
stuff about understanding
which is that's a bad book i'm canceling
harry potter
harry potter is a classic um unless
should be read it
every year um but i think there's
there's great stuff but i think that the
authors have a tendency to cause a lot
of drama and
just like jump on the bandwagon like
yeah there is racism we should stop
reading this
so yeah i just think if you don't if you
can't understand
the great gatsby you're probably not a
very good writer i will say that
if you're a ya author or fan i just want
to know all about
i just want to know all about it it's a
thing i don't understand and i want to
know more about it
yeah i don't understand it either
because my and i'm gonna i'm gonna
preface this this is a stupid thing i'm
about to say but we all think stupid
stuff intuitively sometimes and if you
don't i guess you're better than me
but yeah my thought is always like i
don't know like how young are you you
can't just read
real books oh so
i know that's dumb but that's a bad
thing i know that's a bad thought i'm
acknowledging it
that's a dumb check it is a dumb take
but i'm saying
okay if we're gonna act like no one has
dumb takes i think that we need to
normalize
dumb takes from non-dumb people because
we all have them sometimes and that's
where my dumb brain goes i understand
why we need it because it's
fiction that is from the perspective of
people that age and explores their world
in a literal way so a 14 year old in
2020 doesn't have to read a book about a
35 year old in 1917.
i will i will say mark twain wrote why a
i don't know if you'd call it that but
you know tom sawyer
tom sorry and i even think huck finn i
think kids were still reading it
um and back then there's like a lot of
illiteracy and so like you weren't gonna
sit down with
something like moby dick or something
like much harder
like oh i'm gonna read this fun story um
yeah but why wouldn't i just watch
youtube videos if i'm young why would i
read a book
so as somebody who has read why and does
enjoy some white
books i read it sometimes because it's
just
i feel like sometimes it's more
imaginative or
it's lighter than something else
like if i have to concentrate all day
long and i'm focused and then i have to
read something else then i have to be
focused and
but if i read something why it just
feels more fun and so
it's like emily in paris right i was
just going to yeah
emily in paris it's like yeah i'm not
probably not going to walk away
feeling more intelligent but it's
diverting and enjoyable
wow we really went some places with this
discussion
yeah i mean talked about how i almost
got snatched in china and then we went
into how i hate ya authors
yeah wow this has really been a journey
um
well unless there's any other thoughts
on that i will say
if you and by you i mean the viewer
the listener the one who is consuming
this content but is still an
active part of the conversation don't
get me wrong if you have thoughts on
anything we've talked about today or
anything else we would love to hear them
i mean we'd love to hear them via um
your
your written words or your spoken voice
so you could
get in touch with us so you can give us
a call or you can email us if you want
to call us
call us at 213-534-8807 that is
eight eight zero 213-534-8807 or email
us at culturebinge wisecrack dot co
no m culture binge at wisecrack dot
co um we'd love to hear from you it
means a lot to us to hear from you
um and i don't know how many times i can
say it over and over we love it it's
meaningful to us you're a part of this
family and we want to hear from you
um so i think we have some voicemails
some emails
from the last time so alec what do you
what do you have for us what have you
what have you expertly curated
the the expert we've got two voicemails
the first one
if we could play is about someone asking
us for christmas advice
uh if you can't want advice on how to
ghost your family for the holidays just
message us
it will be it'll keep my mind distracted
i don't have y a to turn
to uh but joy can you play that
hey wisecrack i'm calling for the
culture binge team
uh i'd love to get some advice on
what i should do for christmas uh
regarding traveling home to see family
um so a little background i just got my
first out of college job
um which required me to relocate out of
state from
uh where the majority of my family lives
um and i was hoping to be able to go
home for christmas because
you know we're all keeping our fingers
crossed that by the end of the year
you know things would have turned around
but obviously that is not the case
uh with that said i actually already
have plane tickets home
but generally don't want to go home if
it means
a not being able to see people uh doing
if i did some kind of quarantine or b
if i saw people potentially infecting or
harming my elder relatives both my
parents are in the
uh susceptible age group plus my
grandparents
so it doesn't actually make a lot of
sense
um the complication is that i can't use
the time excuse time off of work because
between paid time off and my company
giving us
a full week between new year's and
christmas day plus weekends on either
side i get like 17 days off at the end
of the year
um of course that's not actually enough
time to
do a full quarantine uh
at home to safely see people so
i'm not really sure what the best
solution is you know
i've talked with my parents about
getting a covered test before getting on
the plane getting one
right right after and you know just
hoping for the best and being safe
uh to in whatever extent i can but
obviously that's
hardly foolproof so if you have any
thoughts on how to uh
how to safely travel home or what to say
to my parents to
soften the blow of canceling my trip i'd
love to hear it
thanks love your show and you guys are
really helping me get through uh this
tough year
bye oh thank you so much
he has such a nice voice oh uh
i my kind of question that makes this
hard to answer is like what are
where are the parents at like do the
parents think the virus is real
do they not think it's real
unfortunately because i think that
changes it but like i'm gonna assume
they understand that it's real but but
sorry
serbia michael do you have thoughts
i do so a friend of mine has to travel
quite a bit for work so if you do decide
to travel home
um she wears she wears two masks and a
face shield
she also wears um like covers up head to
toe like hoodie everything and has like
little gloves
um and she bought this thing on amazon i
was trying to
find it while we were talking but it's
like a spray that she sprays on her seat
and on the tray table and everything and
it's like a
no it's real it's like and it's been
approved by the cdc it says it's like a
sanitizer thing that can kill covet or
whatever so
um i think usually those things say they
don't work on poor surfaces
like which uh well i don't know she
hasn't had covet and she's been
traveling everywhere
um and so travel have fun
get out there no i'm not saying to
travel but i'm saying that i think
he's trying to do a harmony yes she is
um then do that
so um you can get the test before and
after
maybe stay in a hotel if you do stay at
a hotel hilton does a really great job
with cleaning
unless they are paying us money to say
this on the podcast
we are not giving free ads to him so
hilton does a really great job so you
can maybe stay there at night while you
get like a rapid test done
um and then if you don't go maybe you
can do like a zoom call
i know it sounds super boring but you
can do like a zoom
christmas call um and maybe try to play
a game or
like ship presents and then open them on
the call together
and maybe like plan something for next
year like
later in the year this we have something
to look forward to
okay so i feel like we're doing good cop
bad cop now so i feel like
serbia's good cop i'll quickly be bad
cop okay i want to be back
up too okay also if anyone from hilton
is listening
sir we deserve something for that please
give her a gift certificate for like a
long weekend at the hilton resort of her
choice
um okay here's what i think i think you
shouldn't go
and i think it's hard and it's really
hard and i know that
i think you said you just graduated
recently the sad thing is it never
really gets easier to like say no to
parents
because that pressure is very real so i
just want you to know i very much
empathize with that and i'm very much
lucky that i'm not getting that these
days um
but i think there's a way to just say
i'm not going to come home this
christmas
i love the [ __ ] out of you guys i'm
going to miss you so much and this
sucks but i just want to be safe i don't
want to be anxious about this and i
don't even want there to be a 1
chance that i get you
or anyone else sick that said you know
let's figure out something fun to do in
the meantime we can watch the same movie
we'll sing some carols together
over zoom and let's make christmas 2021
just you know let's blow the goddamn
roof off that time
um but i just i think you can say that
and i think long term
they will understand that said it's
going to be a bummer there's no there's
no way for this not to be a bummer
yeah i i agree with michael and i i mean
my
personal take and again this is
contingent on if they think the virus is
real and generally respect like
public health authorities but i would
just be like listen i
you know public health authorities are
basically begging people
begging and pleading to please please
please please please stay home
you know thanksgiving we haven't even
seen the effects of it but
if you want to stall a little bit in two
weeks i'm sure the numbers will be a
[ __ ] nightmare
um and so i'd be like they're being us i
just feel like
to michael's point i don't want to get
you sick also
i mean you know i know that they're the
ones at risk but you know you could get
it from them even you know if you're
quarantining and see them and then you
get on a plane
and with the plane everyone focuses on
you know like sanitizing your space but
you know what i've been reading is a lot
of times it's like the actual airport
itself you have to get on you're
mingling with people people aren't
wearing their mask
and you know masks do have a protective
benefit but
the the best protection is when other
people are wearing masks
of course being very far away from them
um and so
while there is a benefit to wearing a
mask and protecting yourself it's not as
protective as
you know making sure everyone else
around using a dum-dum which you can't
control
and then on the the question of the
testing public and i'm not just armchair
public healthing but like this is
you know public health experts are
saying uh tests are not like a reliable
way to know for certain so you could get
tested on
a thursday um you know and then but then
you're infectious or or sort of develop
the same
symptoms or the viral load that would be
detectable on friday or saturday and so
like a test really will only tell you
if you're good for that day and even
there there's you know a false
negativity rate so i think it's not
you know unless you're going to get
tested like four times and also
quarantine like
that's an idea but i would also say in
general uh
people myself included are not as good
at quarantine as they think they are i
had a family member so they're
quarantining turns out they're going to
the grocery store like four times a day
uh so not trying to say that that you're
bad at it but
yeah just yeah and just quickly before
we move on to the next thing if you need
proof for this
uh we're recording this on december 2nd
the literal headline of the new york
times today says cdc warns against
holiday travel yeah so if you need to be
like
the the you know big brother says i
can't travel there you go the other
option is a lie
say you don't have those days off say
say a project came up
lying is awesome i also think you
shouldn't go but i think
that so saying no to your parents is
hard
even now at my age like it doesn't feel
good it's not going to feel good and on
during the holidays when you're home
alone you're going to feel really bad
and wish that you had gone or maybe
you'll be like i did the right thing
but either way you're going to feel bad
it's going to it's not going to be easy
so you have to do what's best for
your health and the health of those
around you
that's real okay so let's go and thank
you once again for your voicemail
hopefully we have some help um but we
just to be clear we completely empathize
with that you got to do what you got to
do
um alec what's next i think uh we're all
sure on time someone skip the next
voicemail and go straight to emails
uh serbia you requested someone to email
you from who
uh has been to or is involved with the
sex club and the internet responded
yes i'm so excited
so there's an email from lawrence uh
g'day wisecrack i'm writing in today in
response to servie's comments at the end
of episode 41 about her curiosity about
an
underground sex clubs my partner jessica
and i have run a sex club in sydney
australia for almost seven years
it's named our secret spot if you feel
like giving a cheeky plug
i don't mind at all for context we are a
legally run business that is registered
with our local government payer taxes
and insurances
so not entirely underground as the name
would suggest late
last year we opened a second venue here
in sydney we were doing quite well as
business
then covet hit australia went into
indefinite nationwide lockdown
and our business was forced to close we
were extremely concerned that we were
going to lose
all that we had worked so hard for and
lose a lot of money that we just spent
into building our new venue
like so many other small businesses we
had to do what was socially responsible
but we could have ended up bankrupt as a
result it was such an upsetting time
fortunately our landlords came to our
assistance and offered us a rent-free
period until we could trade again
uh we still had to pay outgoing expenses
but at least a major overhead was
removed for us after three months or so
we were permitted to open
by our state government with new
conditions and restrictions got
restrictions on a sex club what does
that even look like but i'm very curious
uh sorry uh
we put uh sorry we put in a covet safe
plan as directed by our department of
health and opened for trade in july
our reopening party was a sellout
initially there was some awkwardness
with people mingling at a bar after
months of being locked down and
quarantined
but the mood of the crowd quickly
changed not as much sex took place as
usual
i suppose people were just happy to be
out and socializing in general
we did lose our original venue though
when the government permitted us to open
the landlord became aggressive and
unreasonable with demands it was ashamed
to close the first
but allowed us to focus on our new baby
something unexpected has happened though
our business has never been more
profitable part of our
uh restriction is to have a fewer number
of clubs this has created scarcity and
as a result the demand for tickets have
never been consistently higher we know
our business is high risk and raises
eyebrows about whether or not we are
doing socially
uh what we are doing is socially
responsible some members of the
community made anonymous calls to the
police to say that we're breaking covet
public health orders
we've had four separate visits from
police on nights we've been trading
the sergeant at our local police station
now knows our business is impressed with
how diligent we are with following all
the regulations and restrictions
so what started as a nightmare has
turned into something quite positive
for us serbia when we can all travel
again you should make the journey down
to australia and visit our club yes
serbia visit their club
bring your interested friend too plus we
don't have a culture of tipping here
either hop
wow i wonder it's just magical wisecrack
correspondent
austin smith has ever been there uh and
sydney local it sounds like up his alley
he seems like that
yeah yeah uh wow that's great i'm
i'm i'm so curious sorry about serbia
i am so excited about this i will 100
go visit there as soon as i can start
traveling again i have a friend who
lives in melbourne and my other friend
the one who's also interested in sex
clubs she and i will both uh
stop by this is fantastic i'm so excited
i'm going to email you because i have so
many questions well lawrence i need to
know
what is what is what do covet safe
restrictions mean in a sec like in a
restaurant you're like people need to
sit six feet apart
but as i understand the goal there is to
[ __ ] people and so i don't
do they wear face masks while they're
[ __ ]
maybe and maybe condoms hand sanitizer
maybe they open all the windows to let
like people slather themselves in hand
sanitizer
then naturally they do the nasty maybe
you're not allowed to kiss
like like i'm pretty woman uh yeah
but um but i applaud you for following
the local regulations whatever they may
be
good and lawrence i know i just want to
say i would love to volunteer and offer
myself if you ever need a guest
bartender
i don't want to participate in sex
activities not cause it doesn't sound
rad i'm just kind of in a situation that
would make that impossible i would love
to guest bartend i'm good at chatting
with people i can make a mean drink let
me know i love to do it i'll and i know
there's not a tipping culture so i won't
expect tips
excellent so after i'm done having sex
with everyone i'll come get a drink
[Laughter]
i think i would have a skill looking at
someone in a postcoital state and
knowing
exactly what they would need at that
point so no i'll call that shot
um do we have uh time for any other
emails alec or uh
yeah we could do uh here here's an email
from
michael about academia hey there
wisecrack last week on culture binge mr
burns made some comments on the value of
non-academia and even made a joke about
alec being lesser in debt
these comments struck very closely to
home for the situation i currently find
myself in i would love to hear your
thoughts and if you'd be so generous
advice for me in this predicament
when i was a senior in high school i was
very overwhelmed and frustrated with
being told that at 18 years old i was
supposed to decide what school i wanted
to attend what career path
to pursue and put myself into a large
amount of student debt
i to make this a reality at 18 years old
i was being asked this question i didn't
even know what i was going to have for
dinner
that night nonetheless what i want to do
for the next 40 years regretfully now at
25 years old the anxiety of this caused
me not to pursue any kind of secondary
education
so i've held down the same job i had in
high school while getting raises and
promotions whenever possible
so i can enjoy a fairly stable lifestyle
being able to comfortably pay my bills
while also being debt free has allowed
me the luxury of putting money back into
savings and safety funds
has made the year with covered fairly
less stress fairly stress-free
for me compared to several of my peers
who have no such savings
however my company will be changing
hands at the first of the year and
suddenly i find myself in the job market
i've been assured by several managers
that have spoken to that having seven
years of tenure at the same job is
incredibly valuable to have on a resume
but i've
always been very insecure my lack of
secondary education with that being said
would you be willing to take a chance on
somebody in my situation what advice
would you have for me in regards
to finding another good job well i've
certainly developed some skills
uh i've spent at my current job i have
always been told that without agree of
some kind most employers won't even read
i won't even read enough your
application to see what such skills
would be and all of my advice is
and all sorry any and all advice is
greatly appreciated
best regards michael i have a quick
piece of advice for him which would be
there's
there's a book by these two um design
professors at stanford called designing
your life
and they use design principles to talk
about thinking about things like career
transitioning careers getting the job
and there's a section of the book where
they they talk about how it's like
two percent of people actually ever get
a job from responding to a job
application or an ad they see and most
jobs are got through um different forms
of like networking reaching out talking
to people in exploratory ways
um i think that book could be kind of
helpful and i know it's a i i listen to
the audiobook from the library
for free um so something like that could
be helpful so
that's one recommendation i would have
um
so things are a little different now
than they were
maybe 10 years ago where you need like i
felt like you needed to have an
education in order to get your foot in
the door
now it's more about experience and i
often don't see
education listed anywhere on job uh
job descriptions um if you do feel
uncomfortable about it you can take free
classes on coursera
um or some of these others like udemy i
think or edx and some of these
so you can sign up for those take a free
class and just list it
um you can also uh
create a linkedin profile if you don't
have one and just list all of your
experience and then
write that you are open to become
getting contacted by a recruiter
um i wouldn't let your
not having a degree stop you or make you
feel uncomfortable
because i feel that i have learned
more on the job than i have in my mba
and yeah i i don't think that you should
feel uncomfortable about it can i just
say you could lie
you could just lie too if you put you
into college on your resume no one's
ever going to check that you shouldn't
but i'm just saying you could
yeah especially if it's a for-profit
college that's since gone out of
business and there's like no way to
contact them
um that's a genius i will also say maybe
i brought this up before
uh people in my some of my family's
dutch and
when they came to america uh they just
said they went to a university
that was firebombed by the nazis uh and
so physical paper
back then there was literally no way to
check and they live they they had a long
and successful career at i think ge or
gm
as an engineer wow wait it wasn't well
your grandpa the doctor who didn't go to
medical school
school killed all those people he said
his medical degree wasn't
that young but yeah i i think if it's a
self-esteem thing like i would not like
you know half of entry-level jobs now
are like i have a
i mean my last job i i did like
marketing for a [ __ ] mental health
practice
i had a degree in political philosophy
you know
it's not like i was pulling out beaudry
and being like well what about this
um and that's like all of my friends
they have degrees in history and english
and whatever
they take all these jobs i would not
feel self-conscious about that i mean
the real reality is
i think you're you're uh the biggest
hurdle is that
sometimes these like automated programs
that sort of reject
um resumes like offhand might
have like a filter where it's like if
they don't have a college listed on
their application but for any human
i mean like once you've got i don't know
what you do but let's just say like
you're
a manager in a in a factory if i'm
hiring for other
manager factory jobs i don't give two
[ __ ] like you did the job before you
know how to do it and you work there for
seven years i don't i don't care
and you know even in my experience
hiring people whether it's you know
thinking about like animators designers
stuff like that
people don't care i mean if you've been
doing it before it's harder to get your
foot in the door for an industry you
haven't done before but
if you've done it before nobody cares
well i think the simplest advice here is
figure out what you want to do
reach out to people who currently do
what you want to do and don't ask them
for jobs just reach out and say
hey i'm interested in career switching i
think your work's really cool entering
your field i love it if we could talk in
the normal world you'd offer to buy him
a coffee
you could just say something like post
covered i'm happy to take you out for a
coffee or send you a starbucks gift card
yeah but just have conversations with
people because i i swear to god
most people i know that have jobs they
like did not get that job from seeing an
apple
scene like an ad it's from reaching out
having conversations
um and i know like networking can feel
shitty but it's not when you're just a
genuine real person like you are
who's genuinely curious about what
people do in their fields
you can also follow people on twitter
which is a great way
like people don't realize that that's a
great way to find a job
so if you like have a dream company or a
dream role start following people and
they'll often post
roles on there and they'll be like my
dms are open
and that's a great way to just chat with
people
yeah the one time in my life i ever got
to hire someone that's how i did it
via twitter so there you go wow um okay
i think we probably need to wind things
down
um is there anything else we wanted to
talk about email wise
no i i think that's it thanks for
everyone for calling us for
emailing us serbia is helping one of our
emailers with their uh
what's that called letter of intent
right yeah and their cv
yeah so hit us up hey listen if we i'm
gonna say this now
and with no ability to definitely make
this happen i love it when people ask
for advice we'd love to help you if we
get enough advice things we'll do a
mailbag special where we just do advice
and go through emails and voicemails the
whole time so just hit us with those
maybe we do before the holidays that'd
be a fun special everyone alex face
right now is like why is burn saying
this i'll never let him do that sorry i
was running
i was reading the comments this person
says again this dan
bilzerian person i don't know who they
are oh i know who he is
they say that i look like them or am
them so
you are sending a picture to culture you
are not wise but you look like them but
he's one of the worst dudes ever but you
do kind of look like oh
okay well just the it's the beer in
there he's a hand he's a good looking
guy he just happens to be piece of [ __ ]
so we're going to wind things down um
once again email us
culturevillewisecrack.com call us
213-534-8807
hit us up real hard and we'll do a
mailbag special also rate and review the
podcast tell us what cocktail would be
tell us what nation we would be in terms
of what we remind you of geopolitically
or what u.s president we must remind you
of um
and then if anyone does notice any weird
audio stuff on my end on this episode
and they can cut this out in the edit if
they need to it's because i had some
audio difficulties
sorry for that we appreciate your
patience um before we go
last thing serbia and alec if people
want to find you follow you on twitter
to try to get a job with you
um how can they do that siri patel 22 on
twitter
and you definitely don't want to work
with me
[Laughter]
i'm i'm at wisecrack alec michael
o'burns on twitter and the other stuff
and i have absolutely no hiring or
firing power in any way shape or form
um but thank you so much we will be back
in two
weeks write review call in the meantime
and we will see you then thanks guys bye
[Music]
you